This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Most of the American West is owned by the federal government. About 85% of Nevada, 61% of Alaska, and 53% of Oregon. The list goes on. And there have always been questions about how this immense swath of land should be used. Should we allow ranchers to graze cattle, or should the Western land be a place where wild animals can roam free and be protected? Or is it land we want to reserve for recreation? As you can imagine, there is no consensus on the answers to those questions, but there are a lot of strong feelings. And over the years, those strong feelings have sometimes bubbled up to the surface and manifested in protests and even violence.
这里是“99%不可见”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。美国西部的大部分土地都归联邦政府所有。大约85%的内华达州土地、61%的阿拉斯加州土地以及53%的俄勒冈州土地都是如此。这样的例子还有很多。关于这片广袤土地应该如何使用，一直以来都存在争议。我们是应该允许牧民放牧牛群，还是应该将西部土地变成野生动物自由漫步并受到保护的地方？或者这是我们想要留作休闲娱乐的土地？正如你所想象的那样，对于这些问题并没有共识，但人们有许多强烈的感受。多年来，这些强烈的感受有时会浮出水面，演变成抗议甚至暴力冲突。
In 2016, a group of armed militants occupied Malhear National Wildlife Refuge in Western Oregon. They were led by a cattle rancher by the name of Ammon Bundy, the son of Cliven Bundy. Perhaps you heard about it, but never really understood exactly what it was all about. Well today, we bring you a story from long reads and Oregon public broadcasting reported by Leah Satilli, and it's the first in the series they put together that looks deeply into the fascinating and even sometimes wonky details of how the American West is managed, why the Bundys are so angry about it, and the religious ideology that undergirds their fight
2016年，一群武装武装人员占领了俄勒冈州西部的马卢尔国家野生动物庇护所。他们由一名名叫阿蒙·邦迪的养牛场主领导，他是克利文·邦迪的儿子。也许你听说过这件事，但从未真正理解这到底是怎么回事。今天，我们将为您带来一篇来自Longreads和俄勒冈公共广播电台的故事，由莉亚·萨蒂利报道，这是他们制作的系列节目中的第一集，深入探讨了美国西部土地管理的迷人甚至有时有些古怪的细节，邦迪家族对此如此愤怒的原因，以及支撑他们斗争的宗教意识形态。
against the federal government. It's an amazing series that spins a good yarn but also resonates with so many aspects of current U.S. politics. It's also about land management, which is really exciting for me personally. This is episode one of Bundyville. Here's Leah Sattilli.
对抗联邦政府。这是一个精彩的系列节目，讲述了一个引人入胜的故事，同时也与美国当前政治的许多方面产生了共鸣。这也关乎土地管理，这对我个人来说非常令人兴奋。这是“邦迪维尔”的第一集。我是莉亚·萨蒂利。
By his own account, Nevada Rancher Cliven Bundy never wanted to start a war with the federal government. He says that if they just left him alone out here in the desert, none of this would have ever started. And if you want to see him as the folksy hero of a modern-day western, you can choose to see him that way. Here's a good starting point. It's a random YouTube video, and it shows a blonde hair little boy, Toddler. He's wearing a dusty red polo shirt, Lou jeans.
据内华达州牧民克利文·邦迪自己所说，他从未想过与联邦政府挑起战争。他说，如果他们只是把他独自留在这里的沙漠里，这一切就永远不会开始。如果你想把他看作是现代西部片中充满乡土气息的英雄，你可以选择这样看他。这里有一个很好的起点。这是一段随意的YouTube视频，画面显示一个金发小男孩，一个蹒跚学步的幼儿。他穿着一件沾满尘土的红色马球衫和宽松牛仔裤。
He lays stunned in the dirt, having just been knocked down, and he's considering whether or not he wants to cry. The boy shakes off his cowboy hat wearing grandpa and putters away. That's what life's all about, raising cowboys. He's tough. See how tough he is? He got rid of her by horse and he's out there going already. Nothing to it, he says. The toddler looks back at his grandpa. He points to the west, and the camera follows.
他茫然地趴在泥土里，刚刚被撞倒，正在考虑自己到底要不要哭。小男孩甩开戴着牛仔帽的爷爷，慢吞吞地走开了。这就是生活的全部，养育牛仔。他很坚强。看他有多坚强？他骑马摆脱了纠缠，已经出发了。他说道，这没什么。幼儿回头看了一眼他的爷爷。他指向西方，镜头随之移动。
Patch of bright green grass comes into view against the Nevada desert. It's the color of life, and it stands out in the place where everything else looks dead. This land is our land, this land is a free land. This land is a place that we can enjoy and use. That's Cliven Bundy as he'd like to be seen. The peaceful farmer, home-stepping on his 100-year-old house, of free land. This land is a place that we can enjoy and use." That's Cliven Bundy as he'd like to be seen. The peaceful farmer, homesteading on his
内华达沙漠的背景中出现了一片鲜绿色的草地。那是生命原野的颜色，在一片万物看起来都死气沉沉的地方格外显眼。这片土地是我们的土地，这片土地是自由的土地。这片土地是我们能够享受和使用的场所。这就是克利文·邦迪希望被看待的样子。那个爱好和平的农民，在自己拥有一百年历史的房子里过着家园生活，这是一片自由的土地。这片土地是我们能够享受和使用的场所。这就是克利文·邦迪希望被看待的样子。那个爱好和平的农民，在
168-acre ranch, near Bunkerville, Nevada. But in 2014, just a few weeks after this video was shot, on the same piece of land, Cliven Bundy and his sons were anything but peaceful. They'd raised a militia that was pointing guns at federal agents of what the Bundy's called a tyrannical government. Here he is on stage in Bunkerville, whipping the crowd into a frenzy, demanding that the local sheriff bulldoze the buildings at a nearby national park so that the surrounding community might have free reign of the land He says get the county equipment out there and tear those things down this morning
位于内华达州邦克斯维尔附近占地168英亩的牧场过着家园生活。但在2014年，也就是这段视频拍摄几周后，在同一片土地上，克利文·邦迪和他的儿子们一点也不和平。他们组建了一支民兵队伍，将枪口对准了联邦特工，指责他们是邦迪口中的暴政政府。这里是他在邦克斯维尔的舞台上，煽动人群的情绪，要求当地警长用推土机推平附近国家公园的建筑物，以便周围社区能够对这片土地拥有自由支配权。他说，今天早上就把县里的设备弄到那里去，把那些东西拆了。
The sheriff just stands quietly on stage He's got his thumbs hitched in his belt and the mob heckles in Bundy has more demands. He says the sheriff also has to disarm the park service rangers. Bring me those guns in one hour he says. Who else? They're not bad. They're not bad. They're not bad. They're bad. But we're gonna think of this for more. Depending on how you look at the way this is all played out, Cliven Bundy is either a prophet who's leaving his people to salvation or a cult leader who's let his followers
警长只是静静地站在舞台上。他的大拇指勾在皮带里，暴民们起哄，而邦迪提出了更多要求。他说警长还必须解除公园服务游骑兵的武装。他说，一个小时内把那些枪交给我。还有谁？他们不坏。他们不坏。他们不坏。他们很坏。但我们要为更多的事情考虑这一点。取决于你如何看待这一切的发展，克利文·邦迪要么是一位带领他的人民走向救赎的先知，要么是一位邪教领袖，他带领他的追随者
straight to jail, even death. And how you see Cliven may say just as much about you as it does about the Bundy's. From long reads and Oregon public broadcasting, this is Bundyville, a seven-part series about the Bundy family and how they're changing the American West. I'm Leah Satelli and in 2016 I set out to write a single breaking news story about the Bundy's, but one story turned into several, because every time I learned something new, it would just bring up more questions. Things that seemed unbelievable would turn out to be real. Even when I wasn't writing, I couldn't stop finding new pieces in this really
直接走向监狱，甚至是死亡。你如何看待克利文，可能不仅反映了你对邦迪家族的看法，也反映了你自身的情况。来自Longreads和俄勒冈公共广播电台，这里是“邦迪维尔”，一个关于邦迪家族及其如何改变美国西部的七集系列节目。我是莉亚·萨蒂利，2016年，我着手撰写一篇关于邦迪家族的突发新闻报道，但一个故事演变成了多个，因为每次我学到新东西，都会引发更多的问题。那些看似难以置信的事情最后都被证实是真的。即使我没有在写作，我也无法停止在这个非常复杂的谜题中寻找新的拼图。
complicated puzzle. Most people know roughly what happened in Nevada and Oregon. If not, this first episode is going to bring you up to speed. And then we're going to dive into all the weird stuff that didn't make it on the Nightly News. And the things that have only come to light months and years after most people stopped paying attention. Because the Bundy story is bigger and stranger than I expected. Forget about facts and laws. Because the Bundy story is bigger and stranger than I expected. Forget about facts and laws. More than anything else, the story of the Bundy is about belief and truth. And figuring out which one of those things has more power.
大多数人都大致知道内华达州和俄勒冈州发生了什么。如果不知道，第一集将带你了解最新情况。然后我们将深入探讨所有没有登上晚间新闻的诡异事件，以及在大多数人停止关注数月甚至数年后才曝光的事情。因为邦迪的故事比我预期的还要宏大、诡异。忘掉事实和法律吧。因为邦迪的故事比我预期的还要宏大、诡异。忘掉事实和法律吧。最重要的是，邦迪的故事关乎信仰和真相。并且弄清楚这两者中哪一个拥有更大的力量。
If you believe the Bundy's, then you believe the federal government is trying to enslave the American people. If you believe the feds, then you believe a remote cattle rancher is a domestic terrorist. So did the Bundy Zone the truth? Or is that the property of the U.S. government? That's what I set out to find. Let's think for a second about all the things in history that have started armed revolts against a government. Food shortages, dictatorships, widespread corruption. Where do reptiles fit on that list? For Cliveon, right at the top, here's Aaron Weiss from the Conservation Advocacy Group,
如果你相信邦迪家族，那么你就会相信联邦政府正试图奴役美国人民。如果你相信联邦特工，那么你就会相信一个偏远的养牛场主是个国内恐怖分子。那么，邦迪家族掌握了真相吗？还是说真相属于美国政府？这就是我出发去寻找的答案。让我们花一秒钟想想历史上所有针对政府挑起武装起义的事情。食物短缺、独裁统治、普遍腐败。爬行动物在这份名单上占什么位置？对克利文来说，它们名列前茅，这里是来自保护倡导组织的亚伦·维斯，
the Center for Western Priorities. You know, the whole reason that Cliveon Bundy has been breaking the law and running his cows illegally is because his cows posed a danger to the desert tortoise. It was an endangered species problem to begin with. In the early 1990s, populations of desert tortoise were plummeting in the American Southwest. The tortoises have been around for 15 to 20 million years in the desert, but they compete with cattle
西部优先中心。你知道，克利文·邦迪违法并违规放牧牛群的整个原因，是因为他的牛对沙漠陆龟构成了威胁。最初这是一个濒危物种的问题。在20世纪90年代初，沙漠陆龟的数量在美国西南部急剧下降。这些陆龟在沙漠中已经存在了1500万到2000万年，但它们与牛群竞争
for what little grass there is to eat out there. And the cattle usually win. In the 90s, that landed the tortoise on the endangered species list. It's a common story in the West. An endangered species is threatened by ranching or logging or mining. Regulators and environmentalists step in to preserve the animal. The groups go to court and fight over this one central question.
争夺那里仅存的一点可食用的草。而牛通常会赢。在90年代，这导致陆龟被列入濒危物种名单。这是西部常见的故事。濒危物种受到牧场、伐木或采矿的威胁。监管机构和环保主义者介入以保护动物。各方对簿公堂，并围绕这个核心问题展开争论。
Are the wide open spaces in the West meant to support rural communities, or should they be kept pristine? Historically, the people working the land have had to back off, give up resources in old ways of life, change with the times. But at a certain point, the Bundys decided they just weren't going to change. They were done with federal rules. We ran cattle here, graze this natural resource off this public land, and I abide by all of them about a state law. But I don't recognize United States government as even existing. Since 1948, the bunnies have been growing
西部广阔的开放空间是为了支持乡村社区，还是应该保持原始状态？历史上，在土地上劳作的人们不得不退让，放弃资源和旧的生活方式，随时代变化。但在某个时刻，邦迪家族决定他们就是不肯改变。他们受够了联邦规则。我们在这里放牧牛群，在这片公共土地上啃食这种自然资源，我遵守所有州法律。但我甚至不承认美利坚合众国政府的存在。自1948年以来，邦迪家族一直在他们的160英亩土地上种植
melons and raising cattle on their 160 acres. And for decades, the family also paid the federal government for grazing permit so they could legally ranch on the public land that surrounds the property. For Nevada ranchers, the tortoise listing meant three fewer months each year that they could graze their herds. But Clive and Bundy, in 1993, he started simply ignoring the ruling and kept his cows on the land. You should know that the rates ranchers pay for grazing are like a dollar per cow each
甜瓜和养牛。几十年来，该家族还向联邦政府支付放牧许可证费用，以便他们能够在该财产周围的公共土地上合法放牧。对于内华达州的牧民来说，陆龟被列入名单意味着他们每年放牧牛群的时间减少了三个月。但克利文·邦迪在1993年开始简单地忽视这项裁决，并将他的牛留在了这片土地上。你应该知道，牧民为放牧支付的费用大约是每头牛每年一美元。
year. Ranchers buy the permits because land is expensive, and the majority of land in the west is actually federally owned. But Aaron Wise says that's one of the things that's up for debate in the eyes of the Bundys. Whether or not grazing your cattle on a piece of public land gives you any rights to that property. Cliven Bundy believes he is grazing his cows on his land, and he's going to claim it's
牧民购买许可证是因为土地昂贵，而且西部的大部分土地实际上都属于联邦所有。但亚伦·维斯表示，在邦迪家族眼中，这是有争议的事情之一。在公共土地上放牧牛群是否会赋予你对该财产的任何权利。克利文·邦迪认为他在自己的土地上放牧牛群，并且他会声称这不是联邦政府的土地，实际上是县里的土地，但事实并非如此。
not federal government land, it's actually county land, but it's not. Ranchers in Clark County, Nevada were eventually offered buyouts for their grazing permits to help save the desert tortoise. Nearly all of them took the money and their permits were retired. Everyone except Clive and Bundy. For more than 20 years, Bundy fought in and out of court with the federal Bureau of Land Management. You'll hear about the BLM a lot in this podcast. It's the agency that President Truman created after World War II to manage millions of acres
内华达州克拉克县的牧民最终获得了放牧许可证的买断，以帮助拯救沙漠陆龟。几乎所有人都拿了钱，他们的许可证也被收回了。除了克利文·邦迪，所有人都是如此。二十多年来，邦迪一直在法庭内外与联邦土地管理局进行斗争。你在这个播客中会经常听到关于土地管理局（BLM）的事情。它是杜鲁门总统在二战后创建的机构，旨在管理美国政府拥有的数百万英亩土地，其中大部分在西部各州。但邦迪说这是违宪的。如果你和邦迪家族及其支持者在一起呆上一段时间，他们会递给你一本口袋大小的宪法，并向你讲述他们最喜欢的部分。第一条，第八款，第7项。让我为你宣读那条款。
owned by the US government, most of it in Western states. But Bundy said that was unconstitutional. If you're around the Bundy's and their supporters for any amount of time, they'll hand you a pocket-sized copy of the Constitution and they'll tell you about their favorite part. Article 1, Section 8, clause 7. Let me read that clause to you.
再次强调，这是第一条，第八款，第17项。现在它以“国会有权……”开头。法律学者称之为飞地条款，它基本上说政府需要获得州政府的许可才能使用华盛顿特区以外的土地。邦迪家族声称，即使他们获得了这种许可，联邦政府也只能建造诸如堡垒和军事船坞之类的事情。这种解释的问题在于，它完全忽视了宪法的其余部分。宪法中还有其他条款以及早已尘埃落定的最高法院判例，表明政府绝对可以拥有土地。我们稍后会深入探讨这一点，但同样重要的是
Again, this is Article 1, Section 8, clause 17. Now it starts out that says Congress shall have power too. Legal scholars call it the enclave clause, and it basically says the government needs to get state permission to use land outside of Washington, D.C. The Bunnies claim even when they have that permission, the feds can only build things like forts and military dockyards. The problem with this interpretation is that it completely ignores the rest of the constitution. There are other clauses in long settled Supremeettled Supreme Court cases that say the government definitely can own land. We'll get into that later, but it's also important
要知道，这里的另一个因素是主权公民意识形态。主权公民认为他们是独立于其他国家的独立国家。当你成为自己的国家时，你就不必遵守国家的法律。联邦法院是无效的，联邦法官也不是真正的法官。诸如税收和向联邦机构缴纳的放牧费等事情对你都不适用。克利文和他的儿子瑞安对这些想法调情，称他们不承认美国的司法系统。尽管如此，克利文还是花了二十年时间在法庭上为他对这一条款的解释而战，
to know that the other ingredient here is sovereign citizen ideology. Sovereign citizens believe they are independent nations unto themselves. And when you're your own nation, you don't have to abide by the country's laws. Federal courts aren't valid, federal judges aren't real judges. Things like taxes, and grazing fees to federal agencies don't apply to you. Cliven and his son Ryan, they flirt with these ideas, saying they don't recognize the US justice system. Still, Cliven spent two decades in court fighting over his interpretation of this clause
很少有人听说过这一条款。与此同时，他的牛在他的财产之外很远很远的公共土地上吃草，这些土地属于所有人。牛群在离牧场很远的地方吃草，以至于当土地管理局官员调查他的牛时，他们发现许多牛已经野化了。有些甚至没有烙印，这意味着它们可能是野生出生的。这些围绕濒危物种和土地使用的争端已经持续了很长时间。二十年来，邦迪一直在法庭上为这些事情斗争，而他却一直在输。
few people have even heard of. All the while, his cattle grazed far, far beyond his property on public lands, which belonged to everyone. The cattle were grazing so far from the ranch that when BLM officials surveyed his cows, they found lots of them more feral. Some didn't even have a brand, meaning they were probably born wild. These fights over endangered species and land use have been going on for a long time. For two decades, Bundy fought about those things in court, and he just kept losing.
到2014年，政府表示克利文已经累计拖欠了超过一百万美元的费用。邦迪却有不同的看法。如果我把老旧的放牧费欠给正确的政府，我很乐意支付我的放牧费。这就引出了一个问题：究竟谁才拥有这片土地。联邦政府怎么能拥有内华达州90%的土地？我以为我们是一个主权州。根据我的权利，我是这片土地的管理者。法庭称克利文·邦迪是在侵入美国的财产。顺便说一句，克利文经常用
By 2014, the government said Cliveyn had racked up more than a million dollars in fees. Bundy saw it differently. I would be happy to pay my grazing fees if I owed old grazing fees to the proper government. That brings us to the point of who does own this land. How does the federal government own 90% of the state in Nevada? I thought we were a sovereign state. I am the manager of this land because of my my right. The court says Clive and Bundy is trespassing on the United States property. Just in a side, Clive and often refers to himself
第三人称指代自己。正是这种侵入的概念真正激怒了他。因为当他在2014年接受这次采访时，联邦特工确实在增派人手，准备没收他的牛，以此来抵偿他积欠的费用。谁才是入侵者？谁是那个带着大约200名武装特工包围我的家、我的牧场以及克拉克县部分地区的人。是克利文·邦迪在做这些事情，还是美利坚合众国政府在做
in the third person. And it's this idea of trespassing that really sets him off. Because as he was giving this interview in 2014, federal agents were indeed staffing up to take his cattle as payment for his backlog of fees. Who is the trespasser? Who is the one out here with like 200 armed agents that surrounded my home and my ranch and parts of Clark County. Is Clive and Buddy doing those things or is the United States government doing
这些事情？那是他的崩溃点。你拒绝把牛交给他们。而我已经在法律、政治和媒体上花费了20年时间。现在是时候穿上靴子，我想我们要表明立场了。邦迪从未公开号召进行武装对峙。他暗示那是他唯一的选择。这似乎归结于如果我们想完成这件事，就得靠人民。
these things? That was his breaking point. You refuse to give them the cows. And I have spent 20 years legally, politically, in the media. And now it's time to get on our boots and I guess make her stand. The Bundy never publicly calls for an arm standoff. He implies that's his only option. It seems like it's down to weed of people if we're going to get it done.
你知道，就像我的睫毛一样，你知道，我，你知道，我没有号召任何民兵或诸如此类的东西，但是嘿，看起来差不多了，让我们把那个拉出来吧。到这个时候，已经是2014年4月，土地管理局正准备一劳永逸地将克利文的牛从土地上赶走。与此同时，全国各地对政府有着各种不满的人通过右翼媒体得知了邦迪的故事。他们当中许多人对养殖牲畜一无所知。他们只是在寻找一场战斗。
You know, the things like my lashes, you know, I, you know, I haven't called no Malaysia or anything like that, but hey, it looks like it's about, let's pull that. By this point, it was April 2014, and the Bureau of Land Management was coming to get Cliven's cattle off the land once and for all. Meanwhile, people from across the country with all kinds of gripes with the government had picked up on the Bundy story through right wing media. Many of them didn't know the first thing about raising livestock. They were just looking for a fight.
嗨，我是詹姆士·A，为了医生的回应，我现在有点生气。其中一人是詹姆士·耶格尔。大约一年前，他发布的一段视频受到了广泛关注。他对奥巴马政府关于提议禁止突击步枪的提案感到愤怒。为了实施更严格的枪支管控。见鬼去吧。
Hi, this is James A. here for Dr. Response, and I'm kind of mad right now. One of them is James Yeager. About a year earlier, a video he posted got a lot of attention. He was angry at the Obama administration over a proposed ban on assault rifles. To impose stricter gun control. Fuck that.
我告诉你们，如果发生这种情况，将会引发一场内战，我很高兴打响第一枪。我不会让任何人夺走我的枪。如果再往前一步，我就要开始杀人了。这些就是蜂拥至邦克斯维尔的那类人。耶格尔成为了克利文的私人保镖之一。在土地管理局特工出现在克利文牧场大约五天后，
I'm telling you that if that happens, it's going to spark a civil war and I'll be glad to fire the first shot. I'm not letting anybody take my guns. If it goes one inch further, I'm going to start killing people. These are the type of people who start flocking to Bunkerville. Yeager became one of Cliven's personal bodyguards. About five days after BLM agents showed up on Cliven's ranch,
发生了这一幕非常混乱的场景。有抗议者向土地管理局特工大喊大叫。特工们带着狗。他们正试图让几辆卡车穿过人群，这时彻底乱作一团。一名特工将一位老妇人推倒在地，突然间，克利文的儿子阿蒙骑着全地形车加速冲过来，停在卡车前面。他下车后与特工争论，那只狗对他狂吠，他踢了
there was this really chaotic scene. There were protesters yelling at BLM agents. The agents have dogs. They're trying to let some trucks through the crowd when all hell breaks loose. One agent tosses an older woman on the ground, and then all of a sudden, Cliven's son amann speeds up on an ATV and stops it in front of the truck. He gets out, trades words with the agents, the dog snaps at him, and he kicks
它一脚。特工使用了泰瑟枪。他扯下泰瑟枪的电极并继续大喊大叫。那段视频在网上疯传，引来了更多的抗议。走开，伙计！走开！走开！走开！走开！走开！走开！那段视频在网上疯传，并为邦迪牧场招来了更多的抗议者。在右翼YouTube用户和博主的网络推动下，情况进一步恶化。他们煽动追随者，在某些情况下告诉他们，带更多的枪去沙漠。再说一次，我要再说一遍，附近地区的任何人，如果你能去内华达州克拉克县，对我们的美国宪法、我们的主权表达一些支持，
it. The agent's tazin. He rips out the taser prongs and keeps y'all out. That video goes viral, and it brings even more protest Go away, man! Go away! Go away! Go away! Go away! Go away! Go away! That video goes viral, and it brings even more protesters to Bundy Ranch. It's helped along by this network of right-wing YouTubers and bloggers. They're inciting their followers, and in some cases telling them, bring even more guns to the desert. Again, I'm going to say it again, anyone in the general vicinity, if you can get the Clark County Nevada and show some support for our U.S. Constitution, our sovereignty,
并在土地管理局的暴政面前挺身而出。政府面临的压力越来越大，以避免潜在的枪战。但对其他人来说，可能发生枪战这一事实促使他们开车前往内华达州。诸如三百分之一组织和誓言守护者等民兵组织在牧场集结。在该视频拍摄两天后，土地管理局特工将邦迪的牛圈在距离牧场几英里外的15号州际公路下方的一个围栏里。克利文告诉人群去把牛抢回来。人们跳上卡车，加速朝几英里外的牛群驶去。去把牛抢回来。人们跳上卡车，加速朝几英里外的牛群驶去。
and stand in the face of tyranny in this BLM. The pressure amounts on the government to avoid a potential shootout. But for other people, the fact that there could be a shootout, that gets them driving toward Nevada. Malicious like the three percenters and the Oath Keepers assemble at the ranch. Two days after that video was shot, BLM agents Corral Bundy's cows and a pen underneath Interstate 15, a few miles from the ranch. Cliven tells the crowd to go get the cows. People hop in their trucks and speed a couple of miles away toward the cattle. go get the cows. People hop in their trucks and speed a couple of miles away toward the cattle.
克利文的另一个儿子梅尔·邦迪骑着马也在那里，他说，我们要把牛夺回来。突然之间，这群看守动物的土地管理局特工被包围了。在高架桥上，有人用狙击步枪指着他们。克利文的儿子们阿蒙、梅尔、瑞安也在那里。他们告诉特工放走牛。他们照做了。野兽无法认清气候。所有的河流都在大堤上放水。
Another of Cliven's sons, Mel Bundy, is there on horseback, and he says, we're getting the cows back. All of a sudden, this handful of BLM agents holding the animals are surrounded. Up on the overpass, there are people pointing sniper rifles at them. Bunch of Cliven's sons, Amin, Mel, Ryan, they're there too. They're telling the agents to let the cows go. And they do. The wild can't read the climate. All the rivers just down on the wall to make the water.
海水。野兽无法让牛通过。视频显示一群人骑着马，挥舞着美国国旗，赶着克利文的牛回到牧场。瑞安·邦迪爬上电线杆，将帽子举向天空。你可能会认为联邦特工会在对峙发生后的几天和几周内提出指控。邦迪家族违抗了法庭命令，并将枪口指向了联邦特工。但政府并没有这样做。
The sea water. The wild can't let the cows go through. There's videos showing a group of people riding horses, carrying the American flag, and hurting Cliven's cattle back to the ranch. Ryan Bundy climbs a light pole and lifts his hat to the sky. You might think the feds would bring charges in the days and weeks after the standoff. The Bundys had defied a court order and pointed guns at federal agents. But the government doesn't.
他们直接离开了。而邦迪家族得到了他们想要的。不是通过法庭裁决，也不是通过妥协。他们通过扮演牛仔，在畜栏的枪战中带去更大更多的枪而赢得了胜利。这就像老西部片一样，但这里的亡命之徒告诉所有人他们才是英雄。不久之后，在俄勒冈州东部的沙漠里，他们又试了一次，但这一次，轮到联邦特工将武器对准他们了。轮到联邦特工将武器对准他们了。
They just leave. And the Bundys get what they wanted. Not by court rulings or by compromising. They won by playing cowboy, bringing bigger and more guns to a shootout at the corral. It was like the old west, but where the outlaws told everyone they were the heroes. And soon in the desert of eastern Oregon, they tried again, but this time, the feds would be the ones pointing the weapons. would be the ones pointing the weapons.
俄勒冈州伯恩斯是该州东南部偏远地区一个一不小心就会错过的小镇。那里有一家杂货店、几家餐馆、一两家汽车旅馆。住在那里的人们要开车两个小时去购物中心、Costco。伯恩斯每个人都认识每个人，当有外地人进城时，他们会注意到。因此，当邦迪家族在2015年底出现时，人们注意到了。他们来是因为阿蒙·邦迪对当地的一个牧牛家族产生了兴趣。哈蒙家族是一群非常好的人。他们是社会的中流砥柱。他指的是德怀特和斯蒂芬·哈蒙，这对父子牧场主在2000年代初因纵火焚烧公共土地而被定罪。检察官试图以破坏政府财产（即
Burns, Oregon, is a rural sneeze and you'll miss it town in the remote southeastern part of the state. There's a grocery store, some restaurants, a motel or two. People who live there drive two hours to go to the mall, to Costco. Everybody knows everybody in Burns, and they notice when outsiders are in town. So when the Bundy's appeared in late 2015, people took notice. They came because Ammon Bundy had taken an interest in a local ranching family. The Hammond are a wonderful people. They are salt to the earth. He's talking about Dwight and Stephen Hammond, father and son ranchers who were convicted of setting fire to public lands in the early 2000s. Prosecutors tried to get them sent away for destroying government property, meaning the
土地）罪名将他们判刑，这需要强制判处五年监禁。但法官拒绝了，哈蒙父子合并服刑15个月。检察官很不高兴。他们对裁决提出上诉，并在2016年1月将哈蒙父子送回监狱服刑满五年。伯恩斯的数百名居民感到不满，并在镇上举行游行以支持哈蒙家族。他们认为这场大火是为了保护他们的财产
land, which carries a mandatory jail sentence of five years. But the judge said no, combined the Hammond served 15 months. Prosecutors weren't happy. They appealed the ruling, and in January 2016, sent the Hammond's back to jail for the full five years. Hundreds of people and burns were upset, and held a march through town and support of the Hammond's. They saw the burn as an effort to protect their property
免受每年夏天肆虐西部的野火侵害。联邦特工称，其中一场火灾实际上是为了掩盖一次非法的鹿猎活动而点燃的。无论如何，阿蒙·邦迪看到的是联邦政府为了夺取他们的土地而迫害一个牧场主家族。嗯，至关重要的是你要明白这里正在发生什么，这个问题的真正核心是什么。这是关于我们的联邦政府恶意接管私人财产，或者在他们毁了牧场主之后用纳税人的钱将其买下。他说，这是一场更广泛阴谋的一部分，一个失控的政府，一个压迫者的集团。如果他们能够控制土地和资源，如果他们能够控制，例如，
from the wildfires that rage across the West each summer. The Fed said one of the fires was actually started to cover up in a legal deer hunt. Either way, Amin Bundy saw a federal government persecuting a ranching family in order to take their land. Um, it's crucial that you understand what's going on here, what this issue is truly about. It's about our federal government taking over private properties adversely, or using the taxpayers' dollars after they ruin the ranchers to buy it. It was part of a broader conspiracy, he said, government, run a muck, a cabal of oppressors. And if they can get control of the land and resources, if they can control, for example,
水，那么他们就能完全控制人民。对阿蒙·邦迪和他的弟弟瑞安来说，这个案子是一个从联邦特工手中夺回土地控制权的契机。这是一个利用对哈蒙家族的不满情绪并将其发酵的机会。在伯恩斯的抗议游行之后，阿蒙·邦迪爬上镇上杂货店停车场的一个雪堆，开始发表演讲。那些知道这里发生了什么并且已经目睹了很多很多年的人，那些准备好为此真正做点什么的人，我请求你们跟着我前往马卢尔国家野生动物庇护所。
the water, then they can have full control over the people. To Ammon Bundy and his brother Ryan, the case was a chance to get control of the land back from the feds. It was an opportunity to take a seed of discontent over the Hammons and nurture it. After the protest march in Burns, Amin Bundy climbed a snow bank in the parking lot of the town's grocery store and he started making a speech. Those that know what's going on here and have seen it for many, many, many, many years, those who are ready to actually do something about it, I'm asking you to follow me and go to the Mallier National Wildlife Refuge.
我们要进行一场坚决的抵抗。他们确实这么做了。阿蒙·邦迪继承了他父亲克利文未竟的事业。在夜色的掩护下，邦迪家族带领一群人前往马卢尔国家野生动物庇护所，这是一个距离镇上30英里的联邦鸟类保护区。他们闯入因冬季关闭而上锁的建筑物，并迅速开始向媒体讲述他们版本的事件经过。他们声称庇护所没上锁，他们直接走了进去。
And we're going to make a hard stand. And that's what they do. Ammon Bundy picks up where his father, Cliven, had left off. Under the cover of darkness, the Bunnies marched a group of men to the Mallier National Wildlife Refuge, a federal bird sanctuary 30 miles from town. They broke into locked buildings that were closed for the winter, and they quickly started to tell the media their version of events. They claimed the refuge was unlocked, and they walked right in.
他们声称有150多名武装人员准备在执法人员到来时保卫庇护所。实际上，他们最多只有几十个人。但几天之内，民兵再次出现。外州的人流涌入野生动物庇护所并驻扎下来。乐队重新聚首。这就是雪地里的邦克斯维尔。邦迪家族胆敢让联邦政府试图阻止他们。他们每天举行新闻发布会，谈论政府不能拥有土地。但与两年前在内华达州的对峙相比，情况有所不同。这一次，许多镇民并不买账邦迪的故事。他们在
They said they had more than 150 armed men ready to defend the refuge of law enforcement came. In reality, they only had a couple dozen at most. But within a few days, the militias showed up again. People from out of state flooded the wildlife refuge and dug in. The band was back together. It was Bunkerville in the snow. The Bundy's dared the federal government to try to stop them. They held daily press conferences to talk about how the government can't own land. But there were differences from the standoff in Nevada two years earlier. Many towns people didn't buy the Bundy story this time. They posted signs
伯恩斯的十字路口张贴标语，上面写着：“民兵，回家吧”。他们举行会议，要求警长切断庇护所的电源，让邦迪家族挨冻。当占领者呼吁提供物资时，世界各地的人们寄来了成箱的性玩具。这个真的很好笑，在一袋阴茎里。他们称他们为“Yal-Keda”，社交媒体上的“香草冰”。他们花钱并浪费钱在所有这些东西上，寄给我们这里。但俄勒冈州和内华达州之间最大的区别在于，这一次开枪了。这发生在占领开始26天后的一条偏远的俄勒冈高速公路上。
at crossburns that said, militia, go home. They held meetings asking the sheriff to turn off the power to the refuge and let the bunnies freeze. When the occupiers called for supplies, people from around the world sent boxes of sex toys. This one was really funny in the bag of dicks. They called them Yal-Keda social media, vanilla ice-s. They spend and waste their money on all this people stuff to send out here to us. But the biggest difference between Oregon and Nevada is that this time shots are fired. It happens on a remote Oregon highway 26 days after the occupation started.
一名线面向联邦特工通风报信，称邦迪家族和其他接管行动的领导人正分乘两辆车前往附近的一个城镇。他们计划在邻县开会，并会见支持他们事业的警长。但在路上，联邦和州执法人员设立了路障。阿蒙·邦迪立即投降。随着俄勒冈州警察逼近，他下车举起双手。
An informant tips off the feds that the bunnies and other leaders of the takeover are driving in two cars to a nearby town. They plan to hold a meeting in the next county over and see the sheriff who supported their cause. But on the way, federal and state law enforcement sets up roadblocks. Ammon Bundy gives up immediately. He gets out, hands up as Oregon State Police close in.
但另一辆卡车里的人并没有放弃。占领行动发言人罗伯特·勒沃伊·芬尼库姆当时正坐在驾驶座上。他曾是一位模范牧场主，向联邦政府支付放牧费用，但在邦克斯维尔事件期间，他皈依了邦迪的看法。我要去见警长。警长正在等我们。所以你们想怎么做就怎么做。但我哪儿也不去。我就在这里。
But the people in the other truck don't give up. Occupation spokesman Robert LeVoy Finnecom is behind the wheel. He was once a model rancher who paid his grazing fees to the federal government, but he converted to Bundy's way of seeing things during Bunkerville. I'm going to meet the sheriff. The sheriff is waiting for us. So you do as you damn will, please. But I'm not going anywhere. Here I am, right there.
你退回去，你现在进来了。来吧，把子弹打穿我。你听到的是在这次拦截过程中从芬尼库姆卡车内部拍摄的视频。和芬尼库姆一起在卡车里的还有瑞安·邦迪、一个名叫维多利亚·夏普的18岁女孩以及拍摄视频的人沙娜·科克斯。取决于你问谁，接下来发生的事情要么是一次暗杀未遂，要么是一次正当的警察开枪。瑞安·邦迪说他们不应该停下来。
You back down there, you came in now. Go ahead, put the ball through me. What you're hearing is a video taken from inside Finnecom's truck during that stop. Inside the truck with Finicom was Ryan Bundy, an 18-year-old girl named Victoria Sharp, and the person shooting the video, Shana Cox. Depending on who you ask, what happens next is either an assassination attempt or a justified police shooting. Ryan Bundy says they shouldn't have stopped.
卡车内闪烁着来自步枪的激光。警察大喊下车。没过多久，芬尼库姆就达到了崩溃点。你们这些家伙正在被击倒。他踩下油门。他猛冲过弯曲的道路，当他到达路障时，他在最后一刻急转弯。这辆车险些撞上一名联邦调查局特工。
Lasers from rifles flash inside the truck. Officers shout to get out. It doesn't take long before Finicom hits a breaking point. You guys are getting hit down. He steps on the gas. He barrels around the curved road, and when he gets to the road block, he swarves at the last minute. The vehicle narrowly misses an FBI agent.
卡车在雪地里撞毁了。在卡车完全停下之前，芬尼库姆跳了车。有人开了两枪打中卡车。他在膝盖深的雪地里踉跄前行。他一直在大喊。起手时他举着双手。然后他伸手去拿夹克口袋。里面是一把上膛的手枪。他又把双手举起来。
The truck crashes in the snow. And before the truck is fully stopped, Finnecom leaps out. Someone fires two shots that hit the truck. He stumbles through knee deep snow. He keeps shouting. His hands are up at first. Then he reaches for his jacket pocket. Inside is a loaded handgun. He puts his hands up again.
然后他伸手。双手举起，伸手。最后，警察确实开枪击中了。他始终没能抓到枪。是的，天哪，他们杀了他在两条该死的腿上。 yeah 该死，为什么他们一直开枪？为什么不把我的头打掉？不，但我们所有人停下，请停下，太荒谬了，因为你很愚蠢。
And he reaches. Hands up, reach. Finally, police do shoot him. He never managed to grab the gun. Yes The boy did they kill him? Got two damn laps. Yeah Damn why do they keep shooting? Why don't you take my head off? No, but all of us Stop Please stop Ridiculous, cuz you're stupid
我只是太荒谬了。我只是太愚蠢了。警察发射了胡椒喷雾弹。勒沃伊在路边的雪堆里流血过多。执法人员一直在努力避免交火。他们等待了26天让邦迪家族离开大院，他们的路障设在一条偏僻的路上，邦迪家族无法呼叫增援。
I'm just ridiculous. I'm just stupid. Police were shooting balls of pepper spray. LaVoy was bleeding out in a snow bank on the side of the road. Law enforcement had been trying hard to avoid a shootout. They waited 26 days for the bundys to leave the compound, and their roadblock was on an isolated road where the bundys couldn't call for backup. and the roadblock was on an isolated road where the Bundys couldn't call for backup.
几天之内，勒沃伊牺牲的地方出现了一座纪念碑，邦迪的一伙人将其称为暗杀，这是暴政的终极典范。阿蒙和瑞安·邦迪在路障处被捕，并被关押在俄勒冈州的监狱里。克利文·邦迪几天后在波特兰下飞机时被捕。他本打算去帮助他的儿子们。相反，他因内华达州邦克斯维尔对峙事件衍生出一系列罪名而被起诉。检察官已经等了两年才设下这个陷阱。
Within days, a memorial popped up where LaVoy had died, and the Bundy crew were talking about it like an assassination, who was the ultimate example of a tyrannical government. Ammon and Ryan Bundy were arrested at the roadblock and went to jail in Oregon. Clive and Bundy was arrested days later as he got off a flight in Portland. He was coming to help his sons. Instead, he was indicted on the litany of charges, stemming from the bunkerville standoff in Nevada. Prosecutors had been waiting two years to spring this trap.
对邦迪家族来说情况不妙。马卢尔占领事件导致了一人死亡，他们即将在联邦法官面前辩称对峙是正当的，因为联邦政府无权拥有州土地。但随后，在法庭上，事情并没有像预期那样发展。审判和裁决，敬请收听接下来的“邦迪维尔”。再次为您播报，我是莉亚·萨蒂利。邦迪家族的法律诉讼在俄勒冈州和内华达州持续了多年，我在两个州都参与了大部分过程。
It wasn't looking good for the Bundys. The Malier occupation had led to a man's death, and they were about to have to argue in front of a federal judge that the standoffs were justified because the federal government couldn't own state land. But then, in court, things did not go as expected. The court case and the verdict, when Bundyville continues. Here again, is Leis Attili. The Bundy's legal fight took years to play out across Oregon and Nevada, and I was there for most of it in both states.
别担心，我不会让你经历枯燥乏味的联邦审判旁听。它远没有电影中描绘的那么激动人心。尽管如此，正是在审判期间，我才真正开始理解邦迪家族对自身故事的信仰所拥有的力量。多年来，他们一直在谈论在美国一些最荒野的地方为自由而战。那些地方，这个国家很少有人去过。然后，在2016年的俄勒冈州呆了两个月，以及2017年底的内华达州呆了一个月，邦迪家族被迫在他们鄙视的城市地区——拉斯维加斯和波特兰——为他们的案件辩护。邦迪家族称，这些自由派大本营正在毁掉美国乡村居民的生活。
Don't worry, I'll spare you the monotony of actually sitting through a federal trial. It's not nearly as exciting as the movies make it out to be. Still, the trials are when I really started to understand the power of the Bungie's belief in their own story. For years, they talked about fighting for freedom in some of America's wildest places. Places, few people in this country have been to. And then, for two months in Oregon in 2016, and a month in Nevada in late 2017, the Bundys were forced to argue their case in the urban areas they despised, Las Vegas, and Portland. Liberal enclaves, the Bundys said were ruining the lives of rural Americans.
花一秒钟谈谈拉斯维加斯联邦法院本身是值得的。它座落在一长条种满棕榈树的道路深处。要到达它的前门，你必须穿过这个巨大的混凝土广场。后来我发现，这是因为这是第一座符合1995年俄克拉荷马城爆炸案后制定的防爆规范的建筑。那是反政府极端分子蒂姆·麦克维的杰作，造成168人死亡。其中许多是儿童。邦迪家族也被贴上了反政府极端分子的标签。人们称俄勒冈州的占领为国内恐怖主义。
It's worth talking for a second about the Las Vegas Federal Courthouse itself. It's set far back from a long palm tree-lined road. To reach its front doors, you've got to walk across this massive concrete plaza. Later, I found out that's because this is the first building to comply with blast-resistant codes put in place after the 1995 Oklahoma City bombing. That was the work of an anti-government extremist named Timothy McVeigh, and it left 168 people dead. Many of them were kids. The Bundy's two have been labeled as anti-government extremists. People have called the Oregon Occupation Domestic Terrorism.
在他们的追随者行列中，你会发现赞同蒂姆·麦克维在1995年所作所为的人。其中一名邦迪的支持者，一个叫加里·亨特的人，是这样谈论麦克维的。他是第一个真正对美国政府采取积极行动的人。那是一栋政府建筑。从这个意义上说，他是第二次美国革命的第一位爱国者。并不是说我赞同这一点，但从客观观察的角度来看，我赞成他做了其他人一直在谈论的事。麦克维谋杀了168人，其中19名是儿童。这个运动中的某些人把他视为什么英雄。当我站在排队进入法庭的长队中时，我想到了这一点。
And within their ranks of followers, you will find people who agree with what Timothy McVeigh did back in 1995. One Bundy supporter, a guy named Gary Hunt, talks about McVeigh like this. He's the first one to actually take an active action against the United States government. It was a government building. And in that respect, he is the first patriot of the Second American Revolution. Not that I agree with it, but from an objective observation, I give him credit for doing what other people had talked about. McVeigh murdered 168 people, 19 of them kids. And some people within this movement see him as something of a hero. I think about that when I'm standing in this long line of people waiting to get into
在俄勒冈州和内华达州的两次审判中，都有带着狗的国土安全警员四处巡逻以寻找威胁。在穿过金属探测器之前，所有这些邦迪的支持者聚集成一个圈，脱下帽子祈祷。然后我想知道为什么我害怕他们，是因为政府告诉我要害怕，还是因为他们真的具有暴力倾向。一旦我进入法庭，审判开始，我很惊讶。
the courtroom. At both trials in Oregon and Nevada, there were Homeland Security officers with dogs walking around looking for threats. Before they walk through the metal detectors, all of these bunnies supporters huddled together in a circle, take off their hats, and pray. And then I wonder why it is I'm afraid of them, because the government is telling me to be, or because they're actually violent. Once I make my way into the courtrooms and the trial starts, I'm surprised.
我以为邦迪家族会在城市里一败涂地。相反，他们蓬勃发展。在拉斯维加斯市中心，邦迪家族伴随着这里的氛围而活跃起来。从法庭外的大厅望去，霓虹灯牛仔在弗里蒙特街的拐角处闪烁。他骑在马鞍上，跨越一匹巨大的、后腿站立的野马。这个家族在拉斯维加斯似乎有宾至如归的感觉。他们陶醉于拥有观众。在审判的第一天，瑞安·邦迪乘一辆白色加长豪华轿车来到法院。在波特兰审判期间，骑马的人在繁忙的城市街道上奔驰。
I thought the bunnies would flounder in the city. Instead, they thrive. In downtown Las Vegas, the Bundys come alive with the atmosphere. From the lobby outside the courtroom, a neon cowboy flickers on the corner of Fremont Street. He's in the saddle, a top-of-the-giant, rearing Bronco. The family seems like they feel right at home in Vegas. They revel in having an audience. On the first day of the trial, Ryan Bundy pulls up to the courthouse in a white stretched limo. During the trial in Portland, writers on horseback gallop down busy city streets.
热狗和汉堡的派对填满了人行道。他们无论走到哪里都制造马戏团般的场景，甚至在法庭上也是如此。审判开始时，检察官和邦迪家族只在少数几件事上达成一致。首先，邦迪牧场发生的事情很重要。其次，克利文·邦迪欠了很多放牧费。他们只是在这些费用应该付给谁的问题上有分歧。第三，克利文的儿子阿蒙和瑞安在两年后带着武装人员前往俄勒冈州接管马卢尔国家野生动物庇护所。但这究竟是一场抗议还是一场武装占领？
A tailgate party with hot dogs and burgers fills the sidewalk. They create a circus everywhere they go, even in court. As the trial starts, prosecutors and the Bundys only agree on a few things. First, what happened at Bundy Ranch was important. Second, Cliven Bundy owes a lot of grazing fees. They just disagree on who he owes them to. Third, Cliven's sons Ammon and Ryan brought armed men to Oregon two years later to take over the Malhear National Wildlife Refuge. But was it a protest or an armed occupation?
除了这些点之外，我感觉自己就像在法庭上观看一场关于另类事实和假新闻的国家辩论。首先在俄勒冈州，然后是在内华达州，政府的律师告诉陪审团这些案件很简单。他们将邦迪家族描述为一个祸害。他们说，克利文和他的儿子们侵入了联邦土地，从美国人民那里盗窃，并使用恐吓手段阻止联邦工作人员
Beyond those points, it was like I was watching the national debate over alternative facts and fake news play out in a courtroom. First in Oregon and then in Nevada, attorneys for the government would tell the jury these cases were simple. They described the Bundis as a menace. They said, Cliven and his son's trespassed on federal land, stole from the American people, used intimidation to stop federal workers
履行职责。他们说，这一切都在证据中。我们有阿蒙和其他人的视频，他们确实这样做了。我们基本上接管了马卢尔国家野生动物庇护所，并且我们计划在这里呆几年。检察官谈到了这两个案件的核心指控。也就是邦迪家族及其追随者密谋阻碍联邦官员履行职责的想法。
from doing their jobs. It was all there in the evidence they said. We have Ammon and the others on video, and they did. We have basically taken over the Malia National Wildlife Refuge, and we're planning on staying here for several years. Prosecutors talked about the main charge in both cases. This idea of the Bundys and their followers conspiring to impede federal officers from doing their jobs.
无法正常工作。他们说，证据里写得清清楚楚。我们有艾蒙和其他人的视频，他们的确这么做了。我们基本上接管了马拉尔国家野生动物庇护所，并计划在那里待上好几年。检察官谈到了这两起案件的主要指控。也就是邦迪及其追随者阴谋阻挠联邦官员执行公务的说法。
They showed a lot of maps. They talked about things most urbanites probably don't care much about, grazing permits, water rights. For a whole day, the FBI described how they picked up evidence of the refuge, how they put in embaggies, and sent it to lab technicians, then the technicians would log it and, ugh, why did I come to court today? The jurors looked bored. In the front row, I watched this one woman nod off, and not just for a second. The judges clerk had to nudge her awake. She giggled to herself. The prosecution had presented its case as if the details were going to be picked apart by other lawyers. But they weren't up against lawyers.
他们展示了大量的地图。他们谈论的大多是城市居民可能不太关心的事情，比如放牧许可、水权。整整一天，联邦调查局都在描述他们是如何收集保护区的证据的，他们如何把证据放进证据袋并送交实验室技术人员，然后技术人员会将其记录在案，然后——呃，我今天为什么来法庭？陪审员们看起来很无聊。在前排，我看到一个女人打瞌睡，而且不只是一会儿。法官书记官不得不推醒她。她自己咯咯笑了起来。控方的陈述方式，就好像这些细节会被其他律师挑刺一样。但他们面对的不是律师。
Ryan Bundy was acting as his own attorney. And when he stood up to present his case, he painted a very compelling picture about life out west. He talked about him and his brothers as children waiting in the waters of the Virgin River, sun rises, moon rises, chasing frogs, hunting rabbits, running across the desert with dogs at their heels. Ryan talked about a family living in an unforgiving land, finding beauty and solace among the desert chattos, finding life in a place where so many things can't survive. And then he talked about jack booted agents, armed for war, federal snipers surrounding
瑞安·邦迪（Ryan Bundy）担任自己的辩护律师。当他站起来陈述自己的案情时，他描绘了一幅非常引人入胜的美国西部生活画卷。他谈到自己和兄弟们小时候在维尔京河（Virgin River）的水中等待日出、日落，追逐青蛙，猎捕兔子，带着狗在沙漠中奔跑。瑞安谈到一个在严酷土地上生活的家庭，在沙漠灌木丛中寻找美景与慰藉，在许多生物无法生存的地方发现生命。接着，他谈到全副武装、如临大敌的穿靴特工，联邦狙击手包围了
the Nevada Ranch. Cliven Bundy said the FBI mounted cameras to record his every move. It was a story about a terrified family, cornereded and needing to defend its way of life. For his side of things, the woman in the jury box was wide awake. Start by saying, I certainly did not see this result coming out again. Kevin Sally is a Portland-based defense attorney who watched the Oregon trial play out in 2016. He says prosecutors had to decide how to deal with the Bundy version of events. One of the choices you always have to make as sort of a
内华达牧场。克利文·邦迪（Cliven Bundy）说，联邦调查局安装了摄像头来记录他的一举一动。这是一个关于一个惊恐万状、被逼入绝境并需要捍卫自己生活方式的家庭的故事。至于他这一边，陪审团席上的那个女人完全清醒了。从这句话开始：我当然没有预料到会有这样的结果。凯文·萨利（Kevin Sally）是波特兰的一名辩护律师，他观看了2016年俄勒冈州的审判。他说，检察官不得不决定如何应对邦迪版本的事件。作为一种...
lawyer when you're facing kind of a counter-argument is how much do you want to kind of engage and thereby sort of dignify that argument as opposed to sort of dismissing it. Oregon prosecutors didn't engage the Bundy version of the story. Even after Ammon talked for days in court about the Constitution, about how he believes it's illegal for the federal government to own land. A belief, legal scholars laugh at. Prosecutors didn't touch it. I mean, I may well have done the same thing, because if you think that your opponents argument is just really, really weak, then you're arguably doing a disservice to your case by kind of bringing it up and elevating it and discussing it. So they hit it away.
当你面对某种反驳论点时，律师要做的选择之一就是，你要在多大程度上参与其中，从而赋予该论点某种尊严，还是将其驳回。俄勒冈州的检察官没有介入邦迪版本的说法。甚至在阿蒙（Ammon）在法庭上连续几天谈论宪法、谈论他为什么认为联邦政府拥有土地是非法的时候——这是一个遭到法律学者嘲笑的信念。检察官根本没有碰触这个话题。我的意思是，我当时很可能也会做同样的事情，因为如果你认为对手的论点真的、真的很弱，那么你把这事提出来、抬高它并进行讨论，可以说是在帮倒忙。所以他们把这事搁置了。
They didn't want to talk about the Bundy's disproven views on the Constitution. Or how many years they'd been working the land. Ammon Bundy sat on the stand for three days talking, telling jurors his family's way of life was under attack. And when it came time for the prosecutors to cross-examine him, they questioned him for less than 15 minutes. In Nevada, prosecutors hit away other things too. They didn't tell defense attorneys that Cliven was right about guys with guns camping out near his property, and his family was being recorded.
他们不想谈论邦迪家族对宪法那些已被证伪的观点，或者他们在那片土地上工作了多少年。阿蒙·邦迪在证人席上坐了三天，讲述并告诉陪审员他家族的生活方式正受到攻击。而到了检察官盘问他的时候，他们对他进行盘问的时间还不到15分钟。在内华达州，检察官也将其他事情搁置一旁。他们没有告诉辩护律师，关于克利文说得没错，确实有带枪的人露营在他财产附近，而且他的家庭被录音了。
At one point, FBI agents disguised as a film crew actually infiltrated the Bundy family home. All of these government missteps, the dismissive tones, the evidence they hid because they said it was irrelevant, it all came across as arrogant. You could hear in the prosecutor's voices that they felt like they had a slam dunk case. They were right, the bundys were not, and that couldn't be clearer.
有一段时间，伪装成摄制组的联邦调查局特工实际上渗入了邦迪家族的家中。所有这些政府的失误、轻蔑的语气、他们因为认为不相关而隐藏的证据，这一切都显得傲慢自大。你可以从检察官的声音中听出，他们觉得自己稳操胜券。他们认为自己是对的，邦迪家族是错的，这一点再清楚不过了。
In the end, Sally says, that seemed to be the government's downfall. But the more I thought about it, I thought, you know, it also, to some degree, kind of presupposes the answer to what a lot of this case was about, and at least some people's mind, which is, you know, do citizens kind of have a right to object and disagree with what the government does with land that it considers to be its own? Here's how one organ juror who asked to remain anonymous phrase the defense's message.
萨利说，到头来，这似乎成了政府垮台的原因。但我想得越多，我就越觉得，在某种程度上，这也预设了很多案件核心问题的答案，至少在某些人的脑海中是这样，也就是说，你知道，公民是否有一种权利，去反对和不同意政府对自己认为是其所有的土地的处理方式？以下是一位要求保持匿名的俄勒冈州陪审员对辩方观点的阐述。
This case is about the death of rural America and that has got me thinking, if your farmers don't have the ability necessarily to prosper in those venues in which they're going to raise whether it's logging or animal stuff it's just got me thinking a lot about that. That message about the death of rural America it worked. At Malier there were armed men patrolling a government facility. They took their guns up a fire tower and dug battle trenches in case the FBI tried to
这个案子关乎美国乡村的消亡，这让我开始思考，如果你们的农场主在他们赖以谋生的领域（无论是伐木还是动物养殖）中不具备繁荣发展的能力，这真的让我对之思考了很多。关于美国乡村消亡的那个信息起作用了。在马卢尔（Malheur），有武装人员在政府设施周围巡逻。他们把枪带上消防瞭望塔，并挖了战壕，以防联邦调查局试图...
come in. But in court, the fact that all those things are illegal, that didn't matter. The Bundy's won. In Oregon, Amin and Ryan Bundy were acquitted by a jury. In Nevada, a case never even got to the jury. The judge declared a mistrial, because prosecutors withheld evidence from the defense. Evidence that actually might have made the Bundys look good in the eyes of the jury. Like how it really was surveilling the Bundys, and prosecutors didn't mention that FBI threat assessments determined the
冲进来。但在法庭上，所有这些事情都是非法的，这并不重要。邦迪家族赢了。在俄勒冈州，阿蒙和瑞安·邦迪被陪审团无罪释放。在内华达州，案件甚至没有走到陪审团面前。法官宣布审判无效，因为检察官向辩方隐瞒了证据。这些证据实际上可能会让邦迪家族在陪审团眼中看起来不错。比如它是如何真正对邦迪家族进行监视的，而检察官没有提及联邦调查局的威胁评估认定...
Bundys themselves were unlikely to be violent. I came into the trial skeptical of the Bundy worldview, but after listening to expert, after expert explain why Cliveon and his sons were wrong in their actions, wrong for their beliefs, I can tell you, at times it's tough to tell which side of the courtroom is actually telling the truth about what the family did. Because the truth about this family, about the movement they've sparked, just isn't that simple. It's a stake. That's for dinner. That's where I'm headed. And God bless America today! After having been arrested two years earlier, Cliven Bundy walked out of jail in the first days of 2018. His cowboy hat was back on his head.
邦迪家族本身不太可能是暴力的。我走进法庭时对邦迪的世界观持怀疑态度，但在听完一位又一位专家解释为什么克利文和他的儿子们的行动是错误的、他们的信仰是错误之后，我可以告诉你，有时很难分辨法庭的哪一方在真正讲述关于这个家庭所作所为的真相。因为关于这个家庭的真相，关于他们引发的运动的真相，根本没有那么简单。是一块牛排。那是晚饭。那是我要去的地方。上帝今天保佑美国！在被逮捕两年后，克利文·邦迪在2018年的头几天走出了监狱。他的牛仔帽重新戴回头上。
His legs free of shackles. He raised a fist in victory. We never had a standoff with the federal government. We had a protest toward County Sheriff. Even the question of whether it was a standoff was still up for debate. Everything was in Bundy's eyes. And I have no contract with the federal government.
他的双腿摆脱了脚镣。他举起拳头以示胜利。我们从来没有与联邦政府进行过对峙。我们是对县治安官进行了抗议。甚至关于这是否是一场对峙的问题仍在争论中。一切都在邦迪的眼中。我和联邦政府没有任何契约。
This court has no jurisdiction over this matter. When since the federal government has a supposed to have an army that comes against we the people. He called out as he had in 2014 for people to stand up to the government. It happened on Bundy Range. They stuck their guns down our throats. Within days of getting out of jail, Cliven was on the steps of the sheriff's office,
这个法庭对本案没有管辖权。联邦政府从什么时候开始拥有据称要对抗我们人民的军队了？他在2014年一样大声疾呼，要求人们站出来对抗政府。这发生在邦迪牧场（Bundy Range）。他们把枪塞进我们的喉咙。出狱后几天，克利文就来到了治安官办公室的台阶上，
an allowed speaker, making demands, just as he had done in 2014. That's when I realized the Bundy's story is hardly over. We're not done with this. If the federal government comes out of them after us again, we will definitely tell them the truth. The truth. After the trials, it felt like the truth was even more difficult to figure out.
作为一名受许可的发言人，提出要求，就像他在2014年所做的那样。就在那时我意识到，邦迪的故事远没有结束。我们还没完。如果联邦政府再次对我们下手，我们一定会告诉他们真相。真相。审判结束后，人们觉得真相更加难以捉摸了。
People traveled from around the country to see the Nevada trial. Journalists, critics, Bundy sympathizers, environmentalists. They came to see the wheels of justice turn out long desired answers about what this is all meant, to understand what the Bundy's actions mean about the future of protest, about the future of the American West, to say something definitive about the movement the family tapped into three years prior. But a mistrial doesn't settle any of those questions. If anything, the proceedings raise new questions
人们从全国各地赶来观看内华达州的审判。记者、评论家、邦迪的同情者、环保主义者。他们来看正义的车轮如何转动出人们长久以来渴望的答案，弄清这一切到底意味着什么，理解邦迪的行动对抗议的未来、对美国西部的未来意味着什么，并对这个三年前被该家族利用的运动做出明确的评价。但是，一场无效审判并不能解决任何这些问题。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是这些诉讼程序提出了新的问题
for people on the fence about the Bundys, everything they stand for. If the Bundys had lost, their occupations would be a footnote to the fight over public plans in the West. Their story would be about a fringe uprising that fizzled out. But because of the government's missteps and the Bundy's court victory, their views on who owns the West have been legitimized, least in the eyes of their followers.
对于那些对邦迪家族及其代表的一切持观望态度的人来说。如果邦迪家族输了，他们的占领行动将只是西部公共土地之争的一个注脚。他们的故事将是一个逐渐消亡的边缘起义。但由于政府的失误和邦迪在法庭上的胜利，他们关于谁拥有西部的观点已经合法化了，至少在他们的追随者眼中是这样。
So if you want to know what the fight over public lands in the West is going to look like going forward, you have to understand the Bundy's, how they think, and how that thinking seduces their followers. To understand the Bundys, you have to trace their long and twisted family tree, and understand the history of backroom deals by politicians trying to undermine the federal government. It's a story of white supremacists and nuclear weapons, and a little-known book that explains
所以，如果你想了解未来西部公共土地之争会是什么样子，你必须了解邦迪家族，了解他们的思维方式，以及这种思维方式如何诱惑他们的追随者。要了解邦迪家族，你必须追溯他们漫长而盘根错节的家族树，并了解政客们试图破坏联邦政府的幕后交易历史。这是一个关于白人至上主义者和核武器的故事，还有一本鲜为人知的书，解释了
the fringe religious beliefs behind Cliven Bundy's whole movement. Next time on Bundyville, I dig in the Cliven's past, and I find some answers. Bundyville is a joint effort by Oregon Public Broadcasting and Long Reads, and it was hosted and reported by award-winning freelance journalist, Leah Satelli. It is produced by Peter Fick Wright and Robert Carver of 30 Minutes West Productions and OPB's Ryan Has. I highly recommend you subscribe to the rest of Bundyville and read the print pieces by Leah on Long Reads. They are riveting. Ryan Has. in San Francisco and produced, on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown,
克利文·邦迪整个运动背后的边缘宗教信仰。下期《邦迪ville》（Bundyville），我将深入挖掘克利文的过去，并找到一些答案。《邦迪ville》是俄勒冈公共广播电台（Oregon Public Broadcasting）和《长读》（Long Reads）的联合制作，由屡获殊荣的自由记者莉亚·萨特利（Leah Satelli）主持和报道。它由“西边30分钟”制作公司（30 Minutes West Productions）的彼得·菲克·赖特（Peter Fick Wright）和罗伯特·卡弗（Robert Carver）以及OPB的瑞安·哈斯（Ryan Has）制作。我强烈建议你订阅《邦迪ville》的其余内容，并阅读莉亚在《长读》上发表的印刷文章。它们非常引人入胜。瑞安·哈斯。在旧金山，在美丽的市中心广播街区制作，
Bokeland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our true home on the web is 99PI.org. p-i dot org radio tempi p-r-x Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州博克兰（Bokeland）。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入有关该节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（罗曼·马斯，Roman Mars），并在@99PI Ork上@该节目。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但我们在网络上的真正的家是99PI.org。p-i点org电台tempi p-r-x 谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。